dan can we talk about your life as a
daydreamer i
understand that daydreaming is very
important to your creative process
what's daydreaming like for you when you
were a kid and what is it like for you
now
i don't know i always thought you know
you grow up and you get in trouble for
daydreaming and things like that and
but sometimes you just can't help but
stare outside the window and
and let your you know let your mind go
and i remember as a kid
i don't know if you do it you just do it
everyone daydreams until the they
they're told not to
i think and i think i wish um
we we get nourished that more and and
nor
and i think uh there's a lot you know
that could be harnessed through that i
think um
i think that was always a maybe a joke
or
a thought that maybe i could become a
professional daydreamer
and things like that um but i think now
in terms of like
how i apply it um i i apply it
as a way to maybe my own way of
meditating or
my own way of trying to find solutions
and ideas and
and um and maybe my own way of being in
the
moment or the present so i i find
daydreaming
a uh really useful tool for me
in terms of creating um i know it sounds
kind of weird it's
they're stupid but um it's like it
it helps if i'm having like a
if i see or hear things it could lead to
different things so i could just kind of
tune out
you know and focus on that specific
thought or that
specific noise or sound and it could
take me
you know to different um places uh i
don't
sound so like
weird but it's it's it's it's relaxing
you know where have you done some of
your best day dreaming can you do it
let's say
at a coffee shop you can do it i think
i i think yeah i think you could you
could do it anywhere
you could do it um uh
practically not while you're driving but
uh you but
but if you're just sitting sitting about
outside sitting in a park
um sitting by yourself uh um
that you just take a moment and and um
you think of think think of thoughts
think think of ideas
and let that like let that kind of
permeate and
and and lost blossom you know um
you know it could it could be even the
thought of hawaii just the word hawaii
then
it starts then you could focus on the
the sound of it the vials and
and what that takes you there's just
different connections that you can make
so um then it could take you to coffee
to pineapple to to different things and
then your brain is visualizing these
these image
these images and then i think um once
you kind of
get get used to doing that for me uh
i do it just because i
i get lost in thought because something
might i
might be my head and then it takes me
somewhere
and i find that um useful
and is daydreaming the same as
meditation or they're different
um they're probably in the same world
and it's linguistics of it of it
um if you are meditating and focusing
but but i think daydreaming is cool
is because you could set ideas you could
set things and
um in your head and uh and you could
you could try to implement those if you
could you know
remember it it's it's i guess it's it's
the opposite when you dream at night
right
when you're dreaming at night and when
you have all these dreams that pop up of
things all of a sudden you might have a
dream like hey why is that guy in my
third grade class
in my dream you know it just pops up
right and then when you're daydreaming
you're like the same thing i was like
oh but it seems like you're
uh you know you're conscious of that i
think that opens up
um opens up your your creative space
to accept ideas you know and they go oh
like when i get stuck writing i guess
that's why people hey
you know go for you go for a walk you go
this you
how does the ending really work how do
these subplots come together
how does that and then people will say
you know
they fi have ideas in the shower or
these things these moments you know
i think those are important having those
moments um
i think it starts with a little bit of
daydreaming because you're
once you focus too much it's like
you're not seeing the possibilities with
that's
like behind you or beside you you're so
narrow
you're narrowed into the script the
story but if you let go and
start thinking about the cup
that's on the table of your character
and how that cup reminds you of your
grandmother's cup
and then the grammar when she was born
here and then that leads to this oh she
used to love this flower that was purple
maybe that flower ends up
somehow back in your scripts huh you
just never know you know so
it's it's making associations with
things that
that um sometimes don't don't connect
immediately so i think that's what helps
me so so
um i think that's a great tool
especially
um writing but then you have to
there's all these things you have to
find a thread
otherwise they just become images it's
both story you need
you need that thread um so that's the
other
thing now is to pull all that dreaming
together and
have it structured and that's the
that's the battle of screenwriting did
you used to get in trouble in school
for daydreaming with teachers
i might have got a u and use of time
wisely i think
so you know the unsatisfactory thing um
so i think that you know i might have
gotten that
um but i always try to avoid
getting in trouble but you know
doesn't mean you can't be sneaky and and
daydream
well no one's looking so yeah
if you were going to teach a class on
daydreaming let's suppose
you know the the idea of daydreaming has
changed and now
it's more reinforced um let's suppose
they take from different people einstein
different you know just
and you put it in together into a course
what would uh what would day one be like
in your daydreaming course yeah
day one i would um you know just
introduce the thought of it and talk
about
what will what we would do during this
this term
and kind of structure it and go like and
and
and tell folks that um
what is the goal you know what's our
goal with this you know
there's science there is you know
technology there's things but there's
also this thing called mystery
you know so um to offer
and that's where the beauty of new
innovation comes from
i think so i would
first talk about what they you know get
everyone's opinion what daydreaming is
you know i i there isn't a specific
answer that's how you feel
but um then talk about how
we were just so bombarded by visuals and
and
especially nowadays and and not
understanding
um what the visual language is well how
do we why do we
feel certain things when we see certain
type of imagery
you know maybe get in the same page and
and say the first third of our
course would be understanding a visual
language
what does that mean when we drive down
sunset boulevard
why do why do all these colors why what
does yellow and
and purple do to us versus gray
and pink and these things so um
so that helps so then when you're able
to
understand that then maybe you could
start to visualize
and that's um part of daydreaming you
know
daydreaming you want to be a filmmaker
what does that entail i didn't know
but in definitely until
getting off the couch let me start with
that and then definitely
until maybe i should go to half price
books and buy a book
maybe what's the story you think about
story and and then you
you think about themes and then that
could lead lead somewhere
um so yeah well first third of class
uh course talk about visualization how
do we interpret visual language
second third is to apply that to let's
let's let's work on our thoughts and our
way to daydream and recollect those
things and how that could help
and how long could you do it in 30
seconds 30 minutes
whatever and then the last third of the
course would just
to be um to understand what
what we did what's the goal of it and
was it successful
how could we um use this in future
applications
of creative work you know that's that's
what uh
maybe the first class would be like you
mentioned
mystery does mystery always happen
having a does mystery always have to be
let's say solving a crime
or figuring something out in science
could it also be
figuring out a character doesn't even
have to be some
criminal or scientific element it's just
figuring out
who they are why they did something why
they said something like
exactly i think so it encompasses so
much and i think it's
it's like you know i think um i think
that's what's fantastic about it because
it it it incorporates the unknown and
incorporates things that
we maybe have on the tip of our tongue
and we want to
explore and understand it we want to
solve things
we're driven by a mystery we
that takes us um two new new places i
think that's what's
what's uh really neat and dynamic of
understanding how to how to use mystery
in your own work um
to tell stories to create suspense to
to um you know and then to have
resolution
because you know because we need i think
us humans we need closure and
and understanding but we also don't need
to be handheld at least
at least for stories some folks might
but for me as a as a storyteller i'm not
i i always think the audience is smarter
than
definitely smarter than me and and you
don't want to treat them
too like hand holding everything so you
want to leave things
to interpretation but i also don't want
to be so abstract that
no one understands what the story is
about you know so
um so those are two different things i'm
battling with
right now and mystery is a a good way to
you know to keep me inspired and and
and you know work my way through through
life
trying to figure things out what's
what's an example of a hand-held
story from a writer versus something
that's too abstract
um okay i guess every you know probably
david lynch is
uh is that is there um and a handhold
would be
more of you know two plus two equals
four
that that um boy meets girl
they fall in love um
versus boy meets girl four other things
could happen
uh you know things like that um so you
as
a as the storyteller um
it's i always think it's like on
being a chef right we have these
ingredients
and and the way you use it whether it's
you know where where the where it hits
you it's how you use these elements of
story to do it
you want to hand hold someone from the
end and go this person is definitely the
killer
or this person is definitely the bad bad
guy who planted the seed who's
trying to get them to break up and
remarry her or things like that
um uh so it's up to
you know up to each chef and and the
audience
is so vast and diverse like a lot of
people are definitely not going to like
some of the dishes i cook because it's
it's not their flavor on profile
but does that mean
you could deny the execution of it or
the craft of it
it's like if you um don't like country
music but you like
you know uh indie rock you cannot
deny johnny cash was a
skilled and talented musician
it's just a taste so that's what happens
i think in terms of what
how you tell stories and hand holding is
a great
great device but for me as
as a chef i you know i don't want to add
too much salt
kind of like as things goes i'll
leave it to the audience a little bit
more to
piece the flavors together do you think
that people look at daydreaming in a
positive
way that's a tricky question i was going
to say
yes but then i'm going to say no
because everyone will be talking about
it more
and how is that because it's it has more
of a negative connotation because it
means you don't get anything done
maybe if we re rewrite that narrative in
terms of
daydreaming is a step to execution
into work where you're daydreaming of
being a
um making um great leather purses
you know then you that happened where
you're daydreaming of
solving um going to the space you know
these things
it starts with some sort of idea planted
in a
a world that seems so far away
but if you you set it and you do the
work it could be attainable
i'm not saying it all is hap can happen
but
at least it gives you hope that an idea
can be
reached you know tried tried for um
so i think when if you ask
parents maybe they don't think it's a
good
good thing if their kids are always
daydreaming
but um you know
i i i hope they it changes because
um i love that word you know i love the
word dream
it's it's it's it's uh that means
um we are an ideas thought out of
and it could be possible um
but we have to sometimes enjoy that
process of making it
possible than the result the result of
that dream
you know um so that's the tricky part
tricky part how does daydreaming help us
reach our goals
daydreaming you know um it
it helps you start with an idea it helps
you
um be open and i think that
is it's in itself a success
if you are able to open and accept new
ideas and think of
things that are possible
that that helps because we need goals
how does daydream get us there it gives
us a shovel
they give us a tool they give us things
that we
we maybe feel like we we can't
accomplish and
we might make in an excuse hey i can't
get
on this degree because i don't have
money
but you can start by daydreaming and if
you if that daydream
beca makes you become um obsessive
makes you become passionate makes you
become
driven then that that's helpful but if
that daydream
turns into a nightmare then it could
lead you
to another daydream so
that's where i think it's it's useful
because there's many
many chances many doors out there where
um that can open daydreaming
allows you to hop hop around and then
when you want to sit on something then
that
sets a path to your goals
do you ever give yourself a limit though
for daydreaming like okay
i've daydreamed at least an hour today
and i think i've reached my limit now
i'm going to get back to
something that's more linear yeah yeah i
well no i don't think i do it
subconsciously i think
um i think it happens that's why i think
it's a little bit different
than on meditation because you designate
a certain time
maybe i do it so much that i don't even
know i could be washing the dishes
and then though i'm washing the dishes
and
get getting it done i have just i just
went to ethiopia
you know and the ethiopia just opened up
this new
type of um bread that i want to
want to discover while i'm washing
dishes you know it's
so um i don't think you could do enough
maybe i'll go there i'll go the opposite
i was like
until it hinders your goal
i think you need to keep exercising that
muscle
just like walking or breathing or doing
things
and if it helps you um reach goals
then it's useful if it doesn't that
means
uh it's it's it's an excuse
and that's a fine line i think that to
walk
so um and that's the practice and that's
going to be everyone's journey
to to to go hey i've been daydreaming
that's why i don't i'm not getting
anywhere i've been daydreaming
oh that's why i'm here so it's that it's
it's that
uh half um you know glass half full half
empty kind of thing so
it's going to be up to each individual
to kind of figure out if it's
it's if it's for them you know or
they're or if they're doing it too much
you